.
>> ALL RIGHT, MANU RAJU ON
CAPITOL HILL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH MY AUGUST
PANEL.
KEVIN McCARTHY DESPERATELY
TRYING TO GET THE NUMBER OF
VOTES HE NEEDS TO BECOME THE
NEXT LEADER IN THE HOUSE.
HE IS THREATENING SENATORS IF
THEY VOTE FOR THIS $1.7 TRILLION
OMNIBUS SPENDING PACKAGE, THAT
ANY FUTURE LEGISLATION THEY
OFFER WILL BE DEAD ON ARRIVAL
WHEN IT COMES TO THE HOUSE.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THE ONE
REPUBLICAN SENATOR REACTING TO
THAT.
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW IF I BUY
THE THREAT, BUT I FIND IT --
KEVIN'S IN A TOUGH SPOT.
STATEMENTS LIKE THAT, AND
STATEMENTS COPPING FROM HOUSE
REPUBLICANS IS THE VERY REASON
THAT SOME SENATE REPUBLICANS
FEEL THEY PROBABLY SHOULD SPARE
THEM FROM THE BURDEN OF HAVING
TO GOVERN.
>> I MEAN, THIS IS THE EXACT
IRONY.
THE REASON THAT SENATE
REPUBLICANS ARE COMING INTO THIS
DEAL WITH THE DEVIL IN THEIR
VIEW IS BECAUSE THEY LOOK AT
KEVIN McCARTHY AND HIS GANG OF
FLYING MONKEYS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
LEGISLATE.
>> THEY WERE SAYING IT'S GOING
TO BE DEAD ON ARRIVAL ANY
BECAUSE OF THE COMPOSITION OF
YOUR CURRENT CONFERENCE.
THIS IS THE SECOND TIME KEVIN
McCARTHY HAS TRIED TO FLEX ON
MITCH McCONNELL WHEN HE DOESN'T
HAVE THE VOTES TO BE SPEAKER.
HE IS HAVING TO WHIP HIS SPEAKER
VOTE IN A WAY I'VE NEVER SEEN.
I THINK THERE IS AN EXPECTATION
THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE
MULTIPLE ROUNDS OF VOTING.
>> DEFINITELY.
>> FOR SPEAKING WITH THE HOUSE.
I THINK HE HAS BIGGER THINGS TO
WORRY ABOUT THAN TRYING TO
THREATEN SENATE REPUBLICANS.
I MEAN, YOU SAW SENATOR CRAMER
IS NOT EXACTLY A SQUISH.
>> NO.
HE IS GOING TO VOTE AGAINST IT.
>> HE IS A PRETTY STRONG
REPUBLICAN.
ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW.
>> I LOVE THAT QUOTE.
THE VERY REASON THAT SOME
REPUBLICANS FEEL THEY SHOULD
SPARE THEM FROM THE BURDEN OF
HAVING TO GOVERN.
YOU'RE READY FOR SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
THAT'S THE BURDEN YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET.
>> I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT
THE FACT THAT A LOT OF THESE
THINGS WERE ALREADY GOING TO BE
DEAD ON ARRIVAL.
THIS IS A PREVIEW OF WHAT'S TO
COME IN A REPUBLICAN-RUN
CONGRESS.
ON THE ONE HAND, DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING THAT, WELL, McCARTHY IS
DOING WHATEVER HE CAN TO BECOME
SPEAKER.
OKAY.
BUT THEN WHAT HAPPENS IF HE DOES
BECOME SPEAKER?
THE IDEA THAT THIS IS ALL GOING
TO END AND HE WON'T HAVE TO
SATISFY THE RIGHT ANYMORE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S THE
CASE.
IF HE WANTS TO REMAIN SPEAKER,
HE IS STILL GOING TO HAVE TO PUT
UP WITH A LOT OF THESE DEMANDS.
IT'S NOT JUST FIGHTING BETWEEN
MITCH McCONNELL AND DEMOCRATS AT
THIS POINT.
YOU'RE SEEING THIS INTERPARTY
FIGHTING.
YOU HAVE FOLKS LIKE RAND PAUL,
WHO ALSO DON'T WANT THE DEFENSE
SPENDING IN THIS.
THIS IS DEFINITELY WHAT YOU CAN
EXPECT.
>> REPUBLICAN HOUSE, RUN IS
DOING A LOT OF WORK.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE DEFINITELY
POPPING THE POPCORN.
AND ACTUALLY, SENATOR MITT
ROMNEY SLAMMING McCARTHY FOR
THIS THREAT AS WELL.
HE SAID WE'RE ENDURING THE SILLY
SEASON OF A CAMPAIGN.
FOR MOST OF US, THAT'S OVER
AFTER YOU GET ELECTED.
BUT HE IS RUNNING FOR SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE, SO THE SILL LICENSE
SILLINESS IS STILL EVIDENT.
THAT'S LIKE CUSSING FOR MITT
ROMNEY.
>> I THINK KEVIN McCARTHY IS
DOING WHATEVER HE CAN RIGHT NOW
TO BE SPEAKER, AND HE THINKS HE
HAS TO PLAY A PART OF HIS CAUCUS
WHICH ARE MAGA REPUBLICANS THAT
HE NEEDS TO HAVE THEIR SUPPORT
IN ORDER TO WIN.
THE FUNNY THING ABOUT IT, ALL OF
YOUR BILLS ARE DEAD ON ARRIVAL.
HE MUST HAVE FORGOTTEN WHAT
HAPPENED IN THIS NOVEMBER
ELECTION.
DEMOCRATS STILL HAVE CONTROL OF
THE SENATE.
AND SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT ANY
BIPARTISAN BILL IS DEAD ON
ARRIVAL.
SO YOU HAVE NO INTENTION TO
ACTUALLY DO ANYTHING FOR THE
WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHO
BARELY GAVE YOU A MAJORITY.
AND HE IS MISSING THE MARK YET
AGAIN.
AND TO YOUR POINT, IF THIS IS
WHAT WE HAVE TO LIVE THROUGH FOR
HOWEVER LONG, IF HE CAN EVEN
BECOME SPEAKER FOR HIS SIX DAYS
OR TWO YEARS OF SPEAKERSHIP, I
DON'T THINK IT'S GOING PLAY WELL
FOR THE REPUBLICANS YET AGAIN.
>> IT'S SO -- IT'S SO DIVISIVE
THAT EVEN MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, A MAGA REPUBLICAN, AND
LAUREN BOEBERT, A MAGA
REPUBLICAN, WHO I DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW DISAGREED ON ANYTHING, THEY
ARE NOW OPENLY FEUDING BECAUSE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE IS, FOR
SOME REASON, ALIGNED WITH KEVIN
McCARTHY.
I GUESS TRUMP IS TOO.
AND LAUREN BOEBERT IS PART OF
THIS SUPER MAGA CAUCUS FLEXING.
TAKE A LISTEN TO LAUREN BOEBERT.
>> MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE SAYS
KEVIN McCARTHY IS GOING TO BE A
GREAT SPEAKER.
>> I'VE BEEN ALIGNED WITH
MARJORIE AND ACCUSED OF
BELIEVING A LOT OF THE THINGS
SHE BELIEVES IN.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN THIS, JUST
LIKE I DON'T BELIEVE IN RUSSIAN
SPACE SLAVES.
RISKS YOU A HARD NO?
>> BOEBERT IS NOT ONLY AGAINST
McCARTHY, ALSO IS NOT IN FAVOR
OF JEWISH SPACE LASER.
>> THAT WAS SOME SHADE THERE.
AS MUCH AS I LIKE TO POP THE
POPCORN AND WATCH THIS FIGHT,
IT'S ACTUALLY AN IMPORTANT POINT
THAT LAUREN BOEBERT IS
UNDERSCORING, WHICH IS THE RIGHT
FLANK WANTS TO HOLD ON TO THE
MOTION TO VACATE.
THEY WANT TO HOLD ON SO THEY CAN
MAKE KEVIN McCARTHY'S LIFE HELL.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY A PROCEDURAL
TOOL THAT ALLOWS ANY SITTING
MEMBER TO ISSUE A VOTE OF NO
CONFIDENCE AT ANY POINT.
>> TO REMOVE THE SPEAKER AT ANY
MOMENT.
THIS IS WHAT KEVIN McCARTHY IS
LIVING IN FEAR OF.
IF HE CAN MAGICALLY GET TO 218,
WHICH IS AN OPEN QUESTION, HE
COULD END UP HAVING ONE OF THE
SHORTEST SPEAKER SHIMPS IN
HISTORY BECAUSE THIS WILL BE
HELD OVER HIS HEAD.
NOW HOW DEFENSIVE MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE HAS GOTTEN OF
McCARTHY IS FASCINATING TO ME.
SHE DID A MULTITHREAD TWEET
DEFENDING HIM, HIS CONSERVATIVE
CREDENTIALS.
THAT SIGNALS TO ME SHE HAS
PROMISED SOMETHING THAT IS
STRONG.
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS, BUT WHAT
ELSE?
I THINK IT WOULD BE MORE THAN
THAT FOR HER TO PUT HERSELF SO
FAR OUT.
>> ANOTHER POINT THAT STANDS
OUT, THE FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP IS IN FAVOR OF McCARTHY
BECOMING SPEAKER, AND YET YOU
STILL HAVE THESE REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE VERY LOYAL TO TRUMP WHO ARE
AGAINST IT, WHICH ALSO TELLS YOU
SOMETHING ABOUT WHERE TRUMP'S
INFLUENCE IS IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AT THIS POINT, WHERE EVEN
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE JUICE
NECESSARILY TO PUSH McCARTHY
OVER THE FINISH LINE HERE.
>> THE ONLY THING I CAN THINK OF
WHAT TRY TO AVOID THINKING ABOUT
THE WAY BOEBERT AND NATIONAL
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE DO, BUT I
THINK BOEBERT IS THINKING THE
EXTREME OF THE EXTREME MAGA
REPUBLICANS ARE THE ONES WHO
SAVED HER SEAT.
BECAUSE SHE WAS IN A REALLY
TOUGH CONTESTED ELECTION.
>> SHE ALMOST LOST.
SO I THINK THAT YOU WOULD THINK
IT WAS SO CLOSE, THAT YOU WOULD
SAY OKAY, LET ME KIND OF
MODERATE.
BUT FOR SOME REASON, I THINK
THAT SHE IS MAYBE THINKING
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON THAT GOT
HER OVER THE FINISH LINE.
>> THERE IS PART OF THE MAGA
BASE THAT DOESN'T TRUST ANY
REPUBLICAN LEADERS.
CERTAINLY NOT McCONNELL, AND
CERTAINLY NOT KEVIN McCARTHY,
WHO HAD A FLASH OF RATIONALE
AFTER JANUARY 6th AND CRITICIZED
DONALD TRUMP AND QUICKLY GOT
BACK IN THE FOLD.
BUT IT IS INTERESTING HOW MUCH
DONALD TRUMP, DONALD TRUMP JR.,
THAT WHOLE GROUP IS REALLY
PUSHING KEVIN McCARTHY, WHO IS,
YOU KNOW, IF YOU REMOVE THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, HE IS PRETTY
MUCH A TRADITIONAL COUNTRY CLUB
REPUBLICAN, CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
REPUBLICAN.
>> WHO WILL SAY WHAT IT TAKES TO
BECOME SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AT
THIS POINT.
>> RIGHT.
BUT HE IS NOT MAGA IN HIS HEART.
>> I DON'T THINK HE HAS A LOT OF
MOORINGS RIGHT NOW OTHER THAN --
BUT THE THING IS I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH POWER HE IS EVEN GOING
TO HAVE, PARTICULARLY IF HE ENDS
UP AGREEING TO THE MOTION TO
VACATE.
THEN THE SPEAKERSHIP IS
BASICALLY A BETTER OFFICE AND
SOME TCHOTCHKES.
I THINK MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
SAID WHAT SHE WANTS, SUBPOENA
POWER.
SHE SAID THAT IN AN INTERVIEW
SOMEWHERE.
SO YOU HAVE TO IMAGINE --
>> SHE WANTS TO BE ON OVERSIGHT,
RIGHT?
>> IT SEEMS LIKE SHE IS PART OF
THE MAYORKAS GROUP.
>> SHE WANTS TO IMPEACH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY.
>> AND SO I THINK THAT THERE --
A LOT OF THINGS HAVE BEEN
PROMISED ON THE INVESTIGATIVE,
OR IT SEEMS CLEAR IF THEY'RE NOT
BEING NAKEDLY CLEAR ABOUT IT.
AND REALM TWO, WHICH IS ANOTHER
REASON FOR HER, BECAUSE IT GIVES
HER MORE POWER TO BACK McCARTHY.
>> YOU CAN'T LOSE IN THIS MOMENT
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
MASSIVE SPENDING BILL WHICH I AS
A CONSERVATIVE PROBABLY TAKE
ISSUES WITH, BUT WE'VE GOT TO
FUND THE GOVERNMENT.
IT'S ACTUALLY A GIFT TO KEVIN
McCARTHY TO GET THIS DONE IN THE
NEXT FEW DAYS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> IF HE DOES END UP BECOMING
SPEAKER JANUARY 3rd, THE LAST
THING HE WANTS IS TO BE DEALING
WITH THIS IN FEBRUARY AND
PUNTING IT TO NEXT YEAR WHEN
HE'S GOT A SLIM MAJORITY, HE'S
GOT A RIGHT FLANK THAT HAS NO
BUSINESS WANTING TO HELP HIM.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO RELY ON
DEMOCRATS TO PASS IT.
HE IS PRIVATELY WISHING THAT
THIS BILL PASSES.
HE JUST CAN'T PUBLICLY SAY IT.
>> GOING BACK TO WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT TRUMP.
HIS STATED FEAR IS IF YOU DON'T
HAVE KEVIN McCARTHY, THEN YOU'LL
GET SOMEONE WHO IS MORE LIKE
PAUL RYAN.
SO YOU COULD WIND UP WITH
SOMEONE MORE MODERATE.
DEMOCRATS FEAR THAT WILL
ACTUALLY HAPPEN IS YOU'LL END UP
WITH SOMEONE FAR MORE
CONSERVATIVE THAN KEVIN McCARTHY
WHO WON'T WORK ON BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
AND WITH THE PRESIDENT.
AND SO THEY'RE BETTER OFF WITH
KEVIN McCARTHY.
SO THAT'S HOW HE IS ESSENTIALLY
BECOME THE CONSENSUS CANDIDATE.
>> BUT WHAT'S HIS END GAME?
IF YOU FLEX YOUR MUSCLE NOW AND
IT ATROPHIES IN SIX DAYS IN
CONGRESS BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
WORK ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS.
NICE TO SEE YOU ON THE SPEAKERS
PANEL FOR